you are a worker or a farmer or a kid in
school whatever you are you've got a job
to do whether you're trading on the
market or doing the dishes at home but
when the day's works them when you come
home to your evenings rest and you sit
and comfortable and familiar
surroundings don't you wonder what it
might feel like to sit in high places
for example have you ever wished you
could sit here in the seat of the
President of the United States recline
on a medieval throne or perhaps you'd
like to be out in the great outdoors
recklessly first in a bosun's chair your
life in your hands all with many lives
in your hands this way do you envy a
pilot seated in his cockpit but death at
his fingertips in a vital target and
range of his bomb sight
don't you wish you was sitting behind
the wheel going a mile a minute as you
race against death
or do you how would you like to tame the
fury of a buckin bronc or crouched on a
bobsled plummeting down a snowbank
mountain
have you ever wondered how it must feel
to sit in judgment or for the last time
in the judgment seat put all these seats
together spin them until they split
apart the throne a cockpit the bosun's
chair the saddle until all is left of
bits and pieces and what do you have the
very same bits and pieces that go into
the making of another kind of seat one
with a magic power all its own a power
to carry on a magic carpet over the
roads of high adventure for the far
corners of the world in of history what
haughty spirit is this chair intended
for pardon me folks would you like to
thrill of your lives simply by sitting
down in a magic chair come on he's not
talking - yes I am I'm talking to
everyone who loves adventure romance
mystery danger
just down the street
go ahead folks why don't you make
believe you're soldiers of fortune
adventure thrilling adventure is waiting
for you in this theater in everything
the ticket waiting for you with a
box-office
that's your passport to faraway places
go on in and sit down and presto a whole
banquet of thrills will be spread before
your eyes
all over the world there are millions of
people who spend three hours a week in
front of a silver screen rich man poor
man
young and old seeking recreation and
escape from work worried in trouble
in the quiet of a movie theater you can
live the thrilling experiences of
history as though you're a part you can
race with the other pioneers at
breakneck speed in a rush for land and a
new hole in the wilderness make a wish
and you can see the great cities of the
world man's own handiwork if you're
seeking the high road to adventure or
the quiet lane to tranquillity you can
find it all here in the magic chair the
movie theater seat you're sitting in
right now